mother's day is this week leslie what is
the sweetest thing that judd and the
girls have done for you
are you taking notes homemade homemade
gifts
or like breakfast in bed you know
um also i like nice bags
you notice how she looked right at you
and said that
[Laughter]
mart have you already made a plan for
this year i don't think they have a plan
yeah
well if you don't have a plan don't
worry we've teamed up with leslie maude
and jergens
to help every mother figure feel loved
and appreciated no matter what the past
motherhood is all women deserve to be
celebrated
on mother's day jurgen's original cherry
almond lotion keeps away the elbow
drought smelly
i remember using jergens at my grand
mercedes house when i was a little kid
the the cherry almond
jergens lotion and that smell just
brings back so many memories and so i
was thrilled to be
in partnership with them and then they
asked mod to do it
and we tried to make them the
commercials
fun and funny as much as we can
they feel authentic what has your mom
meant to you
um awkward she's right here
[Laughter]
i mean i'm so lucky i'm like the best
mom and my mom's
my best friend
[Music]